We're supposed to be the best goddamn country in the world. Is the best we can do? I call bullsh*t.
Alaska leads the nation in sexual violence. It is the national epicenter.
He kidnapped her. He tricked her. And he sexually assaulted her.
Don’t be silent anymore.
Because women – Alaska Native Women – our Native women have no status.
He got a “get out of jail free” pass for what he did to this young lady.
Activists in Alaska are trying to bring
down a judge who gave no jail time to a man who
assaulted a young Native woman. If they're successful, the judge could be voted out during midterm elections.
We are going to hold all of them accountable,
because that's how we end rape culture
in Alaska. We're going to call out
everybody who had a part in this, and
Judge Michael Cory is one of them.
Back in August 2017, an air traffic
controller named Justin Schneider was on
his way to work in the middle of the day,
and stopped by a gas station in the
middle of Anchorage, Alaska. And he
pretended to know this woman who was
hanging out at the gas station. We don't
know this woman by name, but we know
that she was a 25-year-old Alaska Native woman. He pretended to know her and
offered to give her a ride to her
boyfriend's home on the other side of
town, and she accepted and got in the car. Instead, he took her somewhere else,
and he made her get out of the car. He
strangled her with both hands, telling
her that he was going to kill her. She
then passed out, and he ejaculated all
over her face and hair. Then, when she
woke up, he was standing over her with
his pants unzipped. She immediately
called 911. She reported his license
plate. She picked him out of a lineup.
She did everything she was supposed to do.
At some point during this process, the
prosecution dropped three of the felony
assault charges and the sexual charges.
He walked free out of the court, with no jail time, did not have to register as a sex offender.
What Schneider did is not considered a sex crime under Alaska law, but there is
a way his plea deal could have been denied.
Judge Corey was at the end of this. He could have said,
"You know. this is not what we stand for." He could have said something.
The judge in question, Michael Corey, technically could have rejected
the plea deal and called for a harsher
sentence for Schneider. But he didn't, and
many activists say this happens all too often.
I am a white woman, and I think that if I had been the victim in this case,
Justin Schneider would have walked away
with several years of jail time. I do not
think that the state of Alaska takes
sexual assault seriously. I think our
statistics prove it. What we have is an epidemic of sexual assault and violence against women.
Alaska's sexual assault rate
is three times higher than the national
average. 59% of women here say
they're victims of sexual or domestic violence.
So I'm a social worker. I work
with children and families. And I see
lots and lots of domestic violence and sexual assault.
I myself am a survivor of sexual assault,
so I think I understand it and I I think
I know a little bit of what that victim
may have felt.
We know that half of the sexual assaults
in Alaska are against Native women, even
though they only make up 20% of the
population.
Your voice was not silenced like the many Alaska Native women in our community have been silenced. What
happened to my great-great-grandmother,
what happened to many women in my family,
is not going to happen to my daughter.
You know, this is really important to the Alaska Natives, because for a long time, they have been silenced.
Not only for Alaska Natives, but for Indigenous people all across this continent.
I think we have to look at the history of where
we're at in this country and realize
that our institutions were created by
white, womanizing, Indigenous-hating, slave-
owning white men. That is still
affecting us today. I may not be
Indigenous, and I may not be a woman, but
coming from being African-American, being
a vet and having an Indigenous son –
when I need help, when my community comes
under attack, this community is going to
extend its hand out to us too. And that's
the only way we're going to get through
what we're going through.
This isn't the first time a judge has come under
question for lenient sentencing.
California judge Aaron Persky was
recalled after he sentenced Brock Turner
to only six months in jail after Turner
sexually assaulted an unconscious woman.
Enough is enough. We need to send a
message to the bench and to the criminal
division that we are paying attention as
Alaskans. We are informed citizens, and we
are going to use the judicial process to
make ourselves heard in November.
Activists say the judge campaign is just
the first stop. They're on a mission to
reform Alaskan law to better protect women.
We want to send a message to the judges, to the Department of Law and to the legislature
that we're not going to tolerate that anymore.
It does create this deep anger in you.
Judge Cory really allowed a lot of open
wounds to come out. I see so much hope
for change right now. Right now is a time
where women are stepping up and speaking
truth, and I feel like that's a really monumental thing.
Everyone here, everyone in Alaska right now, are the ones that are going to change these systems.
We're not going to let our Indigenous women go missing. We're not going to let them be murdered,
assaulted. And we're certainly not going to let
their perpetrators off with a pass.